welcome to this video playing zen blue
Zen blue from Italy playing a twit could
be six it's that's just fianchetto stuff
the ships are usually not too bad there
okay so we have various transpositions
possible this is quite similar to the
Queen's Indiana's just like I have the
Latvian [ __ ] out 494 maybe 94 and c5
later now we are getting to a hedgehog
type of position double fianchetto
mm yeah this isn't or asleep comfortable
for white I have played this type of
position so often is wide grawr our hand
well no I'm not playing this stuff too
not playing the blitz games for Ross and
always try to get some kind of fight
going even if the position is not really
calling for it hmm Queen Sofia can I can
do this first he's got many points on
dark squares okay he just got rid of the
main issue
hmm
this is even slightly uncomfortable
a five was was really a limb precise
move ya know i'm i'm slightly worse at
least slightly worse maybe even more
yeah he's got c5 scott c5 coming
this is very hardly I want to have a
phone available
a four is just please Ruby six
well we'll get six was terrible why what
the correct position Wow
yeah and I'm just lost I'm just lost wow
this was bad route d6 I mean it's just
winning just winning I can I can try for
tricks but only for some tricks trying
to to get get play of course as always
c5 this is the the issue
if I go look b8c five look a five maybe
maybe
i'm thinking maybe add more precise way
to play which does not mean that this is
a bad but I was fearing that he would
have some boy to improve even further
not sure what the best best blue play
now is I will get app on deck in any
case I think
ya know if we go see six I cannot take
because it's promoting so I need to play
rook c8
don't know I'm like in Canada ruins
rookie 17 Jack wow what a defense but it
seems so old
check can have six this nonsense right
it is
yeah I'm perfectly all right IAM the
active rook should should save the day
King g7 was not precise I should have
played at five immediately damn it's not
not not a big issue
check
yeah there's really not much going on I
can just stay put him
check
check
I can go to the H file so that he does
not have a tempo
yeah it has been a draw all along so
this is some quite logical outcome
I mean the rook endgame at the end of
the draw I mean he got a big big
position before game drawn yeah I wonder
this is a rook a six wow what a crap
move hey this is just jotting I was
thinking okay I need to protect it you
have this and you have this and well
here is least I pay for but it's just so
bad i mean this position is just
incredibly bad around here this is some
yeah maybe maybe he can just can just
improve further not sure how exactly but
I mean this is this I don't know it
looked like you're pretty tough defense
maybe this is the the more testing way
to play this is the other line that I
was thinking about I'll get this back
and I'm close with the King and don't
think I should be in trouble really
the way we wade was played I think it
was perfectly perfect Jack a check I can
just play rock c300 I just overlooked it
I can take the pawn I mean okay not not
getting too excited it's still a draw
but of course I should I should take it
yeah I'm and the way we played it i
think it just it's just just a complete
drum roll cage to missing a chance again
yeah well its many many things are drawn
here because of the very reduced
material okay thanks for watching